the Joe Rogan experience right and you
know right now also like with the rise
of China they're also you know starting
to you like basically some form of like
electronic tyranny right they're able to
just really censor the internet in the
way that's been unprecedented you can't
access Facebook Wikipedia it's none of
them none of these things that you and
you and I can just like open on our our
apps can be accessing in China so the
way they just like control information
and now exporting those same tools to
other authoritarian countries around the
world is that part to me is dangerous
because you know I think both basil and
I came to America with this like alright
this is the place that we can finally be
ourselves and think for ourselves right
yeah and we're starting to see that the
whole world seems to be kind of going in
the other direction did so there was a
shift in China and the shift was it was
initially a completely communist society
and now capitalism at least in a
monetary sense is embraced yes so this
is giant shift in what China actually is
which corresponds to this huge growth is
it possible that in the future this
shift could move on to other aspects of
Chinese culture like discourse or the
way they view the government or even
some form of democracy that was what we
expected that's what we expected that
was the theory but but the way China has
behaved now you know they call it
socialism with Chinese characteristics
that's the official name of this
long-drawn game - you know Institute
market reforms
uh sure in riches for the for the middle
class lifts a lot of people out of
poverty but in the very controlled way
in in the way that's like see that's a
thing about like Asian culture people
understand it's that the there's a
fundamental difference between the China
dream and the American dream right and
si Jinping is outlined what he thinks is
the China dream it's it's it's basically
a top-down way to - it's a goal to
national goal
and basically what they're trying to say
is that okay we're gonna lift a lot of
people out of poverty but you have to
your generation has to make sacrifices
it's not about the individual it's about
building a strong China and implicitly
also about you know ensuring that the
CCP stays in power Chinese Communist
Party stays in power but it's it's that
you might have to give up you know
personal sacrifices for the sake of
China versus the American Dream is is
bottom up
it's about your right to life liberty
and the pursuit of happiness that's it
and if you do that that's the American
Dream and if you achieve a certain level
of happiness you achieve you know it's
all like it's bottom-up it's not it's
not centralized and it's not something
that the Chinese government is kind of
trying to stuff down your throat
and China's willing to play the long
game so it is still a Leninist Lennis
Marxist government see Qing think still
believes in all of that that's why it's
all sorts of Tala terian but it's you
know they know that like the way to get
game power in the world is to get rich
and they did it on some you know on the
backs of on the back of trade with other
countries through very unfair practices
actually many cases so if you think
about like how they I think there's
there are a lot of estimates of how much
they've actually stolen from the United
States in terms of intellectual property
corporate corporate espionage now even
like academia is being infected so how
so
it was arrested the head of the
chemistry department at Harvard oh
that's right yeah but wasn't that they
didn't they think that that guy was in
connection with some weaponized virus
yeah no no I admit I didn't think about
something else
there was an article linking some
Canadian researchers to the virus no but
this was this was different the head of
the the chemistry department and Harvard
was found to have lied about receiving
money from the Chinese government so
there's this program from a thousand
talents program in China basically
they're offering a lot of money the New
York Times had a really good expose you
miss them they basically offer money to
like academic cuz you know it's kind of
sucks to be won here in this end so
flake you're not paid that well but
China's dangling like a lot more money
and okay view if you do research here in
China there's going to be like less
bureaucracy so that's their way to lure
these people in so he was hiding the
fact that he was getting income from me
okay how was he hiding it he just he
didn't report it oh and we put it in the
bank anyway right and so at the end the
day when you do when there's a
relationship there
China owns your research well if you're
researching something sensitive that's a
big issue
[Applause]